He caught their voices, but now Brian the Boom
Mic Guy is breaking his silence. Or, at least,
actor Chris Diamontopoulos has some words to say
about his controversial character on "The Office."
Who would have thought that a simple boom mic
guy trying to make a PBS documentary would cause
so much tension within the "Office" fandom? Okay,
so Chris isn't actually a boom mic operator — but
his character did cause a significant hurdle for
one of TV's most beloved mockumentary couples.
But really, can you blame a guy for developing
heart eyes for Pam Beesley? After all,
Jim Halpert can certainly relate. But
after years of waiting for Pam and Jim
to get together, fans wanted no part
of any threats to their relationship.
When the couple finally defines the relationship
in Season 4, it's smooth sailing from Niagara
Falls and beyond. But then, enter Brian, the Boom
Mic Guy, who steps out in front of the cameras to
shake things up in Season 9 when Pam and Jim
are constantly fighting about Jim's new job.
Looper exclusively spoke to Diamantopoulos,
who set the record straight about Brian and
the fans who love to hate him. At
the mention of his hotly contested
role on "The Office," Chris jokingly
apologized. The actor also agreed that
seeing the couple go through their first
realistic hurdle since coupling was nice.
On what he would say to "The Office" fans who
threw shade at Brian for getting between Jim
and Pam with such a meta storyline, Chris wants
fans to realize that not everything is perfect,
even in the healthiest relationships. He said,
"First of all, I would say, 'Wake up and smell
the reality, folks.' ... In every relationship,
you got to put the extra work in. Sometimes things
go by the wayside, and yeah, that's reality."
"Let's turn the cameras off.
Seriously, guys. Enough. Enough."
And for anyone who tends to forget, actors
are not their characters. It's super uncool
to harass an actor just because you don't
like their character. Chris continued,
"The other thing I would say to them is, 'Hey,
people watching screens — I'm an actor. I didn't
try to break up Jim and Pam. I didn't do this.
I was hired.' The last thing I would say is,
'You can see in Pam's eyes that she's a little
more into Brian. I'm sorry. She doesn't go there,
but she wanted to. So you know
what, guys? Sorry, but f--k you.'"
Of course, if you've ever met Chris,
you'd know that he has a sardonic sense of
humor. So don't go picketing his house, okay?
Chris also wants to assure fans
that Brian's doing great. He joked,
"Brian's living in the Turks and Caicos.
He's a fly fisherman. He's really good."
Though fans can be savage about Brian,
Chris loved working with John Krasinski
and Jenna Fischer. He told Looper,
"They are pros to the nth degree, and I'm such
a fan of what John and Jenna did both on the
show and how their careers have exploded —
rightfully so — off the show. I showed up
on that set very penitent and deferential with
the notion that I am here to help if I could."
Chris foresaw that there would be fan resistance
when he signed on, but that's the gig.
"I knew that any instance where the character
pushed into the territory where the audience
might perceive that there's a threat there would
leave me, the actor, probably being reviled,
but that's my job ... As a fan of the show, it
broke my heart to see their marriage in trouble,
but as a professional actor, I was
ready to give Jim a run for his money."